mesdames messieurs je vous demande
d'accueillir l'offre qui attaque sa
onzième saison au plus haut niveau
celui qu'on surnomme la perle de toul x
fait à tonnerre d'applaudissements
à 12
[Applaudissements]
elle est là elle vient d'arriver aux
mains de me le dire
priorité au direct et qui elle est là ce
soir expressément pour nous elle est à
paris pour quelques jours on a vu sur
les réseaux sociaux
son nouveau petit copain elle est avec
nous ce soir
tout à l'heure du repas gérard depardieu
vous dire voilà qui sera là hélas non on
avait une soeur kylie jenner non avec le
jura but minutes pour donner le coup
d'envoi
kylie jenner qui est avec nous on va
aller la chercher
kylie qui va donner le coup d'envoi de
la 11e saison messieurs on va pas la
faire attendre plus longtemps
merci applaudissements pour elle elle
est là ce soir car il est john a
[Musique]
si vos bras simon fait schéma c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on m'avait vendu c'est
kylie bouder et aux honda en galère de
budget reconnaît vos lunettes pour
combourg que la merde
[Applaudissements]
m
et
j'ai pas trop moi
toi tu es aussi particulier à bordeaux
et c'est pas du tout de la flagornerie
pas ce que c'est
c'est pas facile de me faire ce que tu
fais c'est une énergie krumm qui est que
ça manque
gco non merci alors oui j'ai d'énergie
de la bêta d'une grande gentillesse en
même temps parce que c'est vrai tu
déconnes tu te fout pas de la gueule des
gens de temps en temps on a envie parce
que j'ai vrai qu'il ya pas à pas par
exemple pas se [ __ ] de la gueule des
vous un peu la gt il n'ya pas ya trois
jours dans un poste de police
alors je dis bien cette fois soufflé à
bacchantes surprise j'avais 0,29
ouais t'es là 0,25 mais oui mais je ne
savais pas et donc après je souffle et
là je tombe 0,27 à bout j'en retiens je
reste 10 minutes de plus je suis là mais
c'est ça
regardez
[Applaudissements]
l'expérience la plus incroyable sur
scène non sur un tournage
une bonne question jean-michel j'étais
d'affaires ou bakool pas parce que hier
j'ai regardé parce qu'ils se battaient
sur les réseaux et beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit jean michel maire est beaucoup
plus beau gosse avec cette coiffure
alors donc je me suis dit rentrant chez
moi c'est quand on est le plus moche
qu'on est le plus beau ça les excuses
ouvrir une librairie ou acheter le livre
sur la drague de jean michel maire
alors au nom laquelle il y avait une
maison ne mange pas essuyez vous êtes
très gênante
ces mauvaises réponses en plus donc vous
n'êtes pas aligner un penalty mais nord
c'est à porter mais il faut avoir la
main la matière
un carnage non non non mais l'autre on
dirait qu'elle fait à la gâteau c'est
papa s'appelle le monsieur au 8-ter si
tu prends la boucle ancien annoncé le
béa
[Applaudissements]
tu veux
vendredi j'adore bonjour merci sache el
baz merci a bientot du travail est
reconnue bien entendu louis gignac
oui bien sûr voilà je me permets de
m'immiscer ce soir dans la petite
lucarne rapide sur cette émission de
gaudriole alors habituellement c'est
vous qui vilipendent et les autres
programmes
oui bien sûr c'est moi même oui vignac
fils de françois vinet accès libre aux
diplomates à ses heures perdues que vous
deviez honnête monsieur hanouna sur un
an d'accord vous devez le connaître mon
célèbre père non non non pas du tout bon
et bien vous n'avez pas de culture vous
n'avez aucune culture jeu mafia côté du
livreur de bastos embauches et toi tu es
ou bar en train de boire un pastis vous
êtes toujours désagréable avec les
nouveaux vous mais quelqu'un me rené on
s'est parlé pendant les vacances j'ai
acheté un cadeau j'ai rencontré j'ai
trouvé sur un marché un truc pour lui un
truc du moyen-âge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ni qu'ils vont jamais ils vont jamais
sur le terrain il soit tu fais de la
politique au bar en train de boire un
pastis surfer le monde où bach mais
qu'il te raconter ça m'a dit non tu as
dit voilà on vous dit celui-ci arrivé si
tu me suivaient à marcel aymé turc au
bar et ben tu dénonces admirez donc si
et non tués par szczesny aubin écoute tu
es belle est petit du relais mais ouais
tu débarques tu dis bon c'est vrai pas
beaucoup d'argent si tu devais me payer
à boire au bar à marseille j'y vais tes
patrons quatre cloches
moi je suis pas toi y'a kanak de géval
d'une barre du monde connaît le web
[Rires]
on prend 22 décotes proposées il est là
numéro 1 à la télé à mena
fin de l'école tous m'ont posé une est
là
numéro 1 à la télé and not alone à
celador calme-toi mans à lula toute la
famille est sûre c'est anna avait classé
d'arkham aux animaux
gérer
[Applaudissements]